they're basically doing the majority of
healthcare these healthcare companies
the hospitals that the majority of
healthcare for corona is being done
while you're at home have you realized
that right so they're like they
diagnosed you while you're at home you
call them up you tell them what you got
telehealth all these things are
happening at home right so now that we
can have a global pandemic and you could
diagnose me with all these things at
home do you really think i'ma go to the
[ __ ] City MD and have some fat [ __ ]
give me attitude and tell me to fill out
the same paperwork I've done for the 500
time hell no I'm gonna need that same
energy kept after Corona which is I call
you I tell you the symptoms or I email
my doctor or we FaceTime and I show you
whatever it is you need to see I show
you my glands you tell me if they're
swollen but I'm not going to the [ __ ]
Hospital I'll do that [ __ ] from my work
and it's funny you mention that so 5g
that technology is the main industry
it's gonna help is healthcare wise so it
doesn't just make your phone faster it
just like it allows technology to do way
more and support more bandwidth so it's
like now when they're doing scans and
[ __ ] like that they can come up with
like temperature readers or like tests
that they would take if you went into an
office and they can just do it from your
phone if they create an apple god but
you need that stronger band with the
technology from the 5g in order to in
order to do it so when that 5g does go
worldwide like healthcare is gonna be
that's it everything's at home
telecommunication so now here's the
problem with everything at home hospital
still got to pay rent and these little
CityMD joints they still gotta pay rent
I think a lot of those clothes I think a
lot of them clothes or instead of having
like this main storefront location I
think they go to the second floor some
[ __ ] they'll just end up inside a an
office building somewhere you don't need
signage anymore you don't need to
provide this billboard for the people so
they know where you are
everything's gonna be digital and if I
need to go to you I'll just find out
where you are yeah I'll just find what's
going on but health care changes
drastically and you know who [ __ ]
picks up the slack you know who jumps in
a game is
might bury Amazon now I'm sorry Amazon
so I think Amazon gets into healthcare
big-time big-time because who has more
access to to who you are what you're
doing what you're consuming your
consumption habits in general and what
are you already comfortable going to for
everything you're going to Amazon you
don't think Google would have beat them
to it I don't know Google wants to be in
a health care game and also googles
trash it products like it's great when
it comes to software is [ __ ] when it
comes to hardware like you're right
remember cuz at the end of the day
Google is useful nerds and nerds don't
make [ __ ] this cool they make [ __ ] that
works yeah so all you got to do is like
no doubt that foam was probably dope no
doubt the glasses were dope but you look
like a dork with both of them so they
gotta stay with their dork [ __ ] figure
that out keep dork in it we need dorks
right and then you let the cool
[ __ ] run the cool [ __ ] Amazon I
think it's just gonna have this amazing
access to people and they're gonna have
incredible trust and I truly believe
that people are going to lean into
whatever programs they have and they're
gonna say hey we offer a city MD but the
Amazon version mmm cuz if I'm already
going to City MD and I'm letting some
dude named Hector
give me STD test the [ __ ] ain't
even an MD right he's just City man
Hector is like y'all from Queens I guess
you city brother right so it's like if
I'm already willing to do that you don't
think that I'm willing to trust Amazon
but it's true
that's all City MDS they just keep
passing you off to another nurse yeah
the next nurse is gonna come here the
next nurse the next nurse there's one
doctor that they all share it every one
of them an inner-city tition isn't doing
that's it so I think what's gonna happen
is you're gonna see Amazon jump in a
healthcare game and they're gonna
provide that City MD [ __ ] like the basic
stuff obviously they're not doing
surgery but they can provide you with
all the basic health care needs I mean
if you really want to get into it
low-key how many how many times have we
offered companies that do online
prescription on this very podcast
mhmmm blue chew online prescription
write hymns online prescription all
these places that are already doing an
online prescription right you need a
doctor for it but they're basically
looking at you back yeah you got that
okay boom there you go get your pills
remember when weed wasn't like legal
legal and you need to have a doctor sign
off you went in you're like a guy
headaches the guy we'd probably work
yeah we're already comfortable with
doing [ __ ] over the over FaceTime or
online I don't think we'll ever have to
walk into the hospital unless it's like
surgery or you truly feel like you're
dying and you don't know what's wrong
with you hmm
and I think that's gonna be a major
[ __ ] change I think it could dude it
might [ __ ] over the healthcare industry
but if it falls apart it might drop
costs drastically and by dropping cause
drastically maybe we get to a point
where we can have some form of universal
basic health care hmm maybe not the hot
[ __ ] maybe not the surgery etc but get
your blood work checked every year get
to you know get your random checkups Kay
you twist your ankle whatever we'll look
at it okay we're gonna send you a little
air cast the most basic [ __ ] I think we
could possibly get there that could be
good